this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I'm here today with
comedian extraordinaire Russell Peters
Russell dude Neil time on Startalk first
time first time lists first-time caller
longtime fan thank you for your
enthusiasm and you it's real it's it's I
believe it's real genuine ly I heard
rumors that you want some other show and
said who do you want to have dinner with
and I came up in the list that's you
were the you were the number one person
okay well we're testing you on the show
first
okay make the dinner plan go ahead go
for it yeah before I invite you out well
so thanks for doing this today is an
episode of cosmic queries correct every
now and then we gather questions that
we've either solicited or trickled in
from our fan base and the topic today is
everyday astrophysics you don't know
such a thing huh well I mean would this
be astrophysics for dummies I don't know
actually you've been handed the
questions about the questions you got
all the questions these are actually
really good questions from what I can
see so far okay well that I'm impressed
and I'm like oh good that's a question I
would like to know as well well that's
good you can pick them that way but
before we get into that ditch remind me
you you taught you're on the road all
the time touring constantly constantly
it's all I know thirty years of this so
where is home who's in some bus
somewhere some well technically home is
and well I guess technically home is
Toronto
oh but born and raised born and raised
in Toronto okay but I've been living in
Merc of 13 years Merc of 13 years and
I'll tell you what
any of the H in front of it what so no
it's great to know that you're out there
and you've been doing this a long time
so just trying to try to make comedic
sense of the world for us just so cuz we
need some laughs we did this imitation
this world it needs something and he's
last for that asteroid hits us when you
deal with this get the hell back out
there get back to work so what do you
have for us alright you ready yeah
Renee Douglas where we
duty-bound to make sure the first
question is from a patriot oh yeah
absolutely that's what I'm reading
that's what are you reading okay Renae
Douglas from patreon mm-hmm would like
to know why do you think Mercury and
Venus don't have moons hmm the mercury
is pretty small right mercury is is you
know is in fact mercury is I forgot
whether it's just slightly bigger it's
just slightly smaller than our moon so
but it's small it's it's much denser it
has a huge iron core so it's much
heavier than the moon so it's got planet
mass right but its size is is is small
and it's it's hard to have something
else
orbiting you when you're small you know
Jupiter is huge has more mass than all
the other planets in the solar system
and and it has 60 plus moons orbiting it
60 pits its own mini
planetary system if you will but the act
of being small doesn't preclude having
moons it's just harder when you're that
small and orbiting that close to the Sun
because then you have a gravitational
tug of war okay who who's you know who's
your daddy
who's your gravitational allegiance
who's your gravity daddy who's your
gravity daddy so by the Pluto and is
also small they're like six moons in the
solar system bigger than Pluto but Pluto
has multiple moons the point is that far
out in the solar system there's very
little sort of gravitational
disturbances from other objects so you
can sustain orbits however delicate they
are is it is his size I thought was
thought size is indicative of whether it
was allowed to be a planet or a moon no
well sort of okay
so it turns out if you're really really
small your gravity losses to the
structural integrity of the object so
the rock will take whatever shape it
wants so below a certain size stuff in
the solar system looks like Idaho
potatoes yes I've seen those oh yeah
I've seen them I've seen the picture you
see the picture yeah you've seen in fact
I used to have one here yeah in fact
right up there can you reach up and grab
that yeah you can reach yeah you get it
let's grab that this is a precise model
anyhow so this is a model of an actual
asteroid and this is sufficiently small
that it takes whatever shape the rocks
demand of it all right in rocks to take
their own shape based on the chemistry
and how they formed so but if this
object were larger then the gravity of
the object says I'm trying to get
everything as close to the middle as I
can and there's only one shape you take
if everybody tries to get close to the
middle and it's a sphere so to be a
planet you got to be big enough have
enough mass to be a sphere that's not
the only rule Pluto is big enough to be
a sphere now we say in your orbit we
want you to be dominant we don't want
anything else competing with your orbit
so Pluto it's orbiting what we call the
Kuiper about this thousands of other
objects yes we're burning out there with
Pluto it's littered right it's littered
great word just like the asteroid belt
it's correct littered so nobody in the
asteroid belt owns the space of objects
so they're all asteroids even though one
of the asteroids is big enough to be a
sphere and Pluto is big enough to be
here so the rules are are you big enough
to be round and significant enough in
your group well thank you okay big
enough to be round and it
are you dominant up in your orbit to
have cleared it out so basically you're
the only game in town and if you have to
satisfy both of those then you're a
legit planet in there in the rules are
we
does that could we effectively be seen
as are all our planets as moons for the
Sun I don't see why not
except because the Sun is like alive
with energy we have a different
designation for it okay good it's hot
pots a little overrated but it's a
little warm it's warm yeah you would
Robbie I can take the heat it's just the
humidity on this Nani that I can't
handle so you can think of it that way
and not to like over run this answer but
people wondered a hundred years ago or
more
the turn of the previous century wait a
minute
if the solar system has a star and
planets that orbit it and planets have
moons that orbit them atoms have nuclei
and electrons that orbit them maybe it's
that all the way down goods fare all the
way up right so we have a galaxy there's
a center of the galaxy and our whole
solar system is orbiting the galaxy
maybe it's just solar systems all the
way down but you get to the size of the
atom and there's nothing smaller than
that there's nothing smaller than the
particles that make up the nucleus so
except for antimatter no there's a car
see what I did there yeah so there isn't
some other structure of the natural
world that we have yet discovered nor
that we think is there if you probe the
atom and look at the nucleus and say oh
there's another layer right on down no
we ain't finding it well that was Renae
Douglas from Pittsburgh okay um you want
this one you ready good good it's you
it's up to you don't you ever go in
order okay well that's good yeah what
would the climate be like on Earth if it
wasn't for the axial tilt that was from
Michel grote oh yeah so that's a good
one so this is someone who knows that
Earth is tipped on its axis relative to
our orbit around the Sun so with tip
like this tip 23 and 1/2 degrees in fact
this is exactly that angle that's a
nation in case you didn't you didn't let
me get Earth hold on that's the one I
remember yes so this is a so I'm holding
in my lap for those who are only
listening a map of Earth which were from
our globe thank you let me help you out
with this there and thank you don't hang
on there Astro fella it's a globe and
it's the kind of globe we see in social
studies class because all the countries
are color-coded
but of course Earth from space shows no
such color coding and oh it's weird how
they did that
so anyone tend to believe this globe
much more so we tipped on our axis and
it turns out that because of that
tipping for one part of the year the
northern hemisphere is tipped towards
the Sun and six months later that same
hemisphere is tipped away from the Sun
and if you tip towards the Sun your rays
are much more intense and there's much
more heating of the ground and you get
summertime and around the other side we
tipped away from the Sun there's Sun the
angles are low Ray's the angular raises
low and we experience winter now since
we're part of the same earth as the
southern hemisphere if we're tipped
towards the Sun in the north they're
tipped away from the Sun at the same
time so we experience summer when
Australia experiences winter that's all
that's all that's going so then how does
the Equator stay warm all the time oh
well if the Equator is exactly between
the northern hemisphere in the southern
hemisphere and then they are switching
always between summer and winter then
the equator has no seasons interesting
we can't and wouldn't like it can't have
seasons and when it's even on the other
side it can't have seasons because it is
always exactly between all other seasons
the only way to be that is to have no
season at all and what they do is they
say oh it's the rainy season or it's the
you know the stormy season it makes me
feel good about it so just so they think
they're having a season but
temperature-wise
the equator has no seasons and it's
largely true for all the tropics but
might want to be precise the equator
does not go through season so if you
want to undo the tilt and have Earth's
just pointing straight up and down no
seasons but it would still rotate right
he was still rotate on our axis and
still revolve around the Sun we still
have years but there'd be no seasons and
for anyone for again unless it's just
rainy season versus not right we know
temperature based seasons of any of any
significant measure would we still have
cold and warm and hot let's so I'm
trying to put it
yeah hot water out of the faucet open
cold weather and hot weather or just it
would just be warm all the way around
well no so you would have oh I'm sorry
so the farther away from the equator you
go the cooler would get right right so
now the whole earth is not the same
temperature but at a given latitude
right it's it you don't get seasons
that's all I'm saying so the hottest
part would be the equator and then you
move away from the equator to the poles
and there would be the coldest spot I
don't think you should blame the Polish
for this whatever the poles have done
nothing to you let's see if the poles
are people from Poland then the Polish
are people that are sort of from Poland
yeah the kind of they're from Chicago
I'm pole-ish yeah what else you got
let's see if we were just plopped onto a
gas giant such as Jupiter like when they
need to explain that one to you what
would happen to us assuming we could
survive well if you alright I'll just
keep reading but I hate I'm not an
Astrophysical
come on Jeremy said no you're better
than this the word assuming I think
carries assuming we could survive there
isn't a solid surface we could stand on
so where would we go good question so if
I flunk you down on Jupiter you would
just descend through the clouds okay
Jupiter gets denser and denser and
denser as it goes down if you have a
pressure proof suit that you're wearing
you will continue to fall until you are
about the same density as the
surrounding area and then you just sort
of Bob there and float that's what would
happen so you would find your floating
point you're the floating point so if
you didn't have your pressure suit you'd
be crushed by the atmospheric pressure
that was there but don't they and you
would vaporize because it gets very hot
very quickly is that what happened
ignoring the vaporizing and avoiding
getting crushed you'll fight you'll find
your your your your place your zone yeah
so is that what happened to Cassini
oh no Cassini oh you didn't my boy did
some it's mine or I'm a nerd for this
all very good it's just a quick side
note so you know yeah in 2017 I went to
Chile to the that he's pronouncing that
all I'll announce like I'm not
juillet I'm a gelato I went to the Deaf
Observatory in the european space oh
yeah european southern observatory
yes i went there and i spent two nights
three nights there how I have a friend
knew somebody friends with now Rogers
okay all right you know people and Niall
this guy had invited us all down last
minute now bailed but the rest of us
always isn't it magical it is ridiculous
it is ridiculously magical at the top of
her mountain when it gets dark and you
see out and it's just you and the cosmos
but I thought then I was gonna look
through telescopes and see things and
cuz they have those giant there's no
there's no lenses ya know they just
shoot lasers and I'm not going you laser
is another thing we convinced yeah yeah
the the two reasons why you would shoot
lasers but we can save that for another
question if it ever gets all right but
but the it's it is truly magical to be
on a mountaintop at night it is pretty
wild yeah they did pull out like a
little rinky-dink telescope cause look
through telescopes anymore there it's no
it's really not
you thought it'd be this giant eyepiece
waiting for you to walk up yeah like I
thought it would they I thought like
this giant gates of heaven and saw the
pictures and I was like oh my god I'm
gonna look through those and like yeah
no don't look through those yeah it just
sends us data and I'm like well well
that sounds that helped me I gotta read
the data at home alright you want can I
sleep sneak mine in Oh sneak alright
he's gone let me sneak the one I wrote
last you got your own question I do
is that allowed I don't know I'm diggin
ears is that allowed I'm doing I brought
I brought a question okay go go for it
is the Big Bang Theory only for the
observable universe or does it encompass
like like the entirety of everything ooh
so first it's a TV show right finishing
it's highly successful and I've never
watched one episode of my life really
yes
Kylie's one of the most successful shows
ever really so if you type the Big Bang
Theory into Google the show comes up
first right which is far more important
far more important and then next I think
there's a kpop band called Big Bang
there's a yes then they come up next
then the origin of the universe right
these are our priorities it's still
considered a theory
so a theory is the modern word we use to
describe successful understandings of
the operations of nature so quantum
theory
relativity theory evolutionary theory so
people - oh it's just a theory that's
the word we use to describe stuff that
works if you have an idea that hasn't
been tested yet it's a hypothesis oh
okay so it's Einstein's theory of
relativity is Russell's hypothesis about
something
I have no idea until it's put out and
then it gets fully explored and
investigated and tested and has other
predictive value then we're good to go
with it so the Big Bang is our
understanding of the existence and
expansion of the universe in which we
live and it goes not only to the edge of
the observable universe but it would
include the universe beyond that it's
just that it's hard to get answers to
that which is beyond our horizon so
colloquially we say it is the theory of
our understanding of the of the visible
universe but technically the whole
universe came into existence even the
parts we can't see not in what we call
the Big Bang so so from nothingness
comes somethingness yes okay by the way
just it's just to put you at ease with
that please because the way you said
that was all pejorative just want you to
know it was I had a little pejorative
you copped a little attitude I was like
and I wasn't really excited with the
answer I didn't really answer anything
funny how do you get something from
nothing
so so let's say you have oh you know let
me save the answer to that okay after
the break the answer this mr. bender
when we come back on Startalk we'll find
out how you get something from nothing
on this edition of cosmic queries
everyday astrophysics
we're back on Startalk cosmic queries
edition everyday astrophysics and
helping me answer as my co-host today
visiting for the first time Russell
Peters Russell hey dude I'm back
I can't go to Netflix without seeing
your face I crazy I get me to watch all
your stuff yeah don't don't waste your
time you're an astrophysicist you're
smarter than this I love you rapport
with the audience it's great it's great
you just make them all feel like they're
the they want to be there so well
hopefully you know I'm captive yeah
unless you have Stockholm Syndrome and I
don't know about it so you've got
questions after that question and it's
on everyday astrophysics yeah bring it
on uh actually you left me hanging on
the last it was a big cliffhanger that
we left and you didn't finish it for me
I forgot and I almost forgot - okay
Greece - me either
oh yeah I did yeah I said nice things
about your hey it's all about me yeah I
was like I'm listening so so the
question was how do you get something
out of nothing
mmm so it's the thing is with energy you
can have positive energy and negative
energy it's not just an emotional thing
it's actually a real physical thing in
the physical universe and if a and each
of those have consequences on space time
and matter and but if you bring them
together it sums to no energy at all so
how does how does this happen so think
about it let's say there's level ground
and then I have a shovel and I put
ground from this part and I stack it
over here
so I'm digging a hole right and making a
making a mound well I can keep doing
this and I can have a hill as
arbitrarily as high as I want and I can
climb to the top of the Empire State
Building but there's a hole next to it
so how did I get that high how is that
even possible
I took the dirt over here and I put it
over here but I might put the dirt back
in and everything's level again so it's
a way to think about what it means when
you have negative energy and positive
energy there's a lot of things we do
where you started with nothing but you
ended with something something that you
care about but in the total picture
it sums to zero that's good no that's a
good explanation from saying that I can
walk away with a go ok and not lose
sleep tonight yeah I would have I would
have lost sleep I'd have been tonight
I'm gonna be sleeping on ok damn it I
should have asked him all right let's go
with I haven't read this one I'm just
gonna read it now and see what I think
and see what it might be it might be a
crappy question we don't know right
Vincent
Zimmerman wants to know where is he
just had Twitter Twitter sure I'm the
town of Twitter what's the most distant
star you can see with the naked eye so
that's an interesting question because I
can answer that two ways so one of them
is the most distant thing you can see
with the naked eye is our nearest
red-blooded galaxy the Andromeda galaxy
and the longest well until the early
1920s it was called the Andromeda nebula
because it was just this fuzzy thing in
the night sky among the stars that trace
out the constellation Andromeda so we
named it after Andromeda and it was a
nebula fuzzy thing and then with better
and better telescopes it wait a minute
this thing is composed of stars wait a
minute this thing is far away wait a
minute this is an entire other galaxy
it's not just a fuzzy thing in the Milky
Way it's another Milky Way well how far
away is it was not close quote close
like these stars we see in the night sky
this is outside of our entire galaxy the
stars you see in the night sky are tens
hundreds a few there are thousands of
light-years away the Andromeda galaxy is
two million light years away and you can
see that with the naked eye I believe I
saw that when I was in Chile you would
have no no no that's too far north there
are other fuzzy objects in the night
side - that's called those were first
described and written about by Ferdinand
Magellan mm-hm
that guy was no Magellan on VII he was
sorry what I should say is Western folk
first learned of these two clouds when
Magellan did his round-the-world voyage
clearly Aboriginal peoples of Australia
knew all about the Magellanic Clouds so
they're named in his honor
the Magellanic Clouds and they would
call clouds at the time they are
galaxies as well yes except the closer
there's a small one and a big one Edna
called the small imagine my client and
the large measure my class yeah they
really went out on the names who would
he tell it like it here they blew the
bank on that one so those are relatively
nearby a couple hundred thousand
light-years away the Andromeda is two
million light-years away
you're not seeing an individual star
you're seeing hundreds of billions of
stars the muddled muddied light the
blended light of hundreds of billions of
stars that comprise the Andromeda galaxy
that is the farthest object visible
would you and a to die and you can't see
that from New York or any light polluted
place just go out in the country side
it'll be there would you um venture to
think that if there are people there
that they could see us the same fuzzy
way we see them oh by all means oh yeah
I think about that all the time
yeah in fact if they were if there was
intelligent life there and they had
detectors and they're looking our way
they would see us not as we are but as
we were two million years ago because
that light is only just now reaching
them Wow so they would not see signs of
what we would call intelligence on earth
yeah we'll see very at least ours now
they would so yeah a andromeda galaxy
there it is
that's pretty awesome yeah I think the
word awesome shouldn't have qualifiers
in front of it something either is or is
not all yeah it's not pretty awesome
it's not similar to awesome it is not a
family of Awesome pretty awesome all
right it's awesome it's also pretty us
pretty awesome this is a completely
different type of question let's try
this mm-hmm this is slightly Angra
slightly angry lugia lugia I don't know
that's their name on Twitter why do
sodium and chloride two extremely toxic
and harmful chemicals combine to form
normal table salt this is the beauty of
chemistry
so you think that a things properties
are somehow inherent mmm in the thing
but the property is what manifests after
you combine it with whatever else is so
so you combine sodium which is a lethal
metal that you can cut with a knife
that's how soft it is and it reacts
violently with water add that to
chlorine which would poison you if you
breathe it mm-hmm okay and put them
together and you get completely
necessary table salt for necessary for
the life so when you put them together
all the chemistry it's a new chemistry
it's a new thing don't think of it as I
need it probably has some of those
properties they used to have no all that
matters is what are its electrons doing
when they talk to your electrons and if
the configuration is different that's
all that matters and the electrons that
manifest themselves to you in table salt
are differently configured than the
electrons that manifests themselves to
you as either sodium or chlorine and for
me the best way to say this I've had a
little paragraph in this in my in one of
my books it was let's take hydrogen
hydrogen is explosive if you have a ball
hydrogen and light a match to it so as
Mexican food carry on thank you for that
clarification in case we did so hydrogen
will explode if you light a match to it
the ball of gaseous hydrogen oxygen
promotes combustion if you have a flame
and add oxygen to it it'll burn faster
hmm combine hydrogen and oxygen you get
water that puts out flames there you go
you know reminds me of reminds me of
George Carlin's old bit about half-way
dirty words words aren't dirty until
they're put together oh okay you know so
he had a follow-on to the seven dirty
words well this was this is old great
material even he said
[ __ ] isn't a dirty word it's in the
Bible mm-hmm and if you go to the
dentist and or the doctor and they give
you a sucker okay
hope you put them together you got a bat
okay so a good point so along those
words mean things you put them together
it means something else yes entirely
yeah
and so I think you can only get nice
words that combine make bad words I
don't think you can take bad words that
combine make a non bad word yeah no well
I mean you know it's the same it's the
opposite maybe a jackass
that's but jack is not a bad word ass is
kind of like a it's a donkey yeah yeah
so it's the same thing once meaning is
everything in language and if two words
together have a different meaning you
know deal with it
don't say wait a minute take it apart
and those have their own separate
meanings therefore that word together
has it no say how it works so it's the
same as the sodium and the chloride
exactly the same as the sodium and
chloride but it works in the opposite
way where sodium chloride come and come
form together make something nice and
they say think beautiful yes yes gotcha
see what I did there for you mm-hmm
you're welcome kid so what else you have
let's see raoul salan are ano and hope
you can do better than that try that
again
listen it's on Twitter what am i doing
alright it's not a good question now
good quickly well what would be the
single most alarming thing that I could
see with the naked eye on oh no oh oh I
mean that's so I got this okay I got
this I'll use that's up for
interpretation I got this yeah okay you
ready yeah I didn't know what the single
most alarming thing I could ever see
with the naked eye was until I saw it
mm-hmm which meant I did not anticipate
it okay you ready yeah ah this is 1999
I'm on the Brooklyn Bridge at two
o'clock in the morning and I'm looking
up because that's how we roll
that's exactly how you're right it's
November I remember this because there's
a meteor shower
hmm okay meteor showers are best
typically after midnight so there I am
and Brooklyn Bridge is a nice you're
away from lights it's still very lit
but you're away from lights as good as
you can I'm a city person it's the best
I can do and I'm there and I'm looking
up and I'm seeing this meteor showers
called the Leonid meteor shower and you
see the streaks of life there's shooting
stars it's beautiful we're getting like
three or four per minute this is a good
rate okay then I saw a new star in the
sky I don't recognize that star and it
just got brighter and brighter and
brighter and then it disappeared then I
saw a puff of smoke and I said whoa whoa
okay so you know what just happened no
you don't know you don't know what I
just witnessed so it was a meteor that
was headed straight towards me oh wow
and the disintegrator straight towards
me there was no streak there was no and
I thought to myself this is the final
moment of my life
it's the best way you could go in all
fairness I'm a it's the most appropriate
we are so accustomed to seeing streaks
of lightning in the sky and some of
those are gonna be headed straight for
you and they're not gonna make a streak
they're just gonna get brighter that
when I realize a split second after that
had happened what I just witnessed I
freaked out I mean not in a cycle I just
intellectually freaked out right and I
said damn that's what that's gonna look
like so that's the that's the most
terrifying thing to look up and see well
there you go Raul it's definitely the
most terrifying thing Neil saw exact
what about you what could alright what
else yeah let's see uh can you explain
why some of the planets in ourselves
this is Ramona von Ahn face bro motive
Oh Ramona Ramona Ramona Ramona Vaughn
can you explain why some of the planets
in our solar system rotate in the
opposite direction retrograde is what
they called it yeah yeah so the planet
Uranus for example
its axis is tipped 98 degrees so it's
rotating upside down but what determines
that bingo because it's going backwards
well no you asking that
I was hoping you gonna ask that question
yeah that's a very intelligent
thought-out question it's if if so if
you take something turning and then I
turn it and then I flip it it's still
turning yeah Who am I to say that's
upside down that's basically your
question yes it's because the right hand
rule okay but Uranus doesn't know that
it's not like Earth what's going on
there okay I'm a lefty I'm a yes it's
called a right hand rule so here's how
you do it okay
so hold up your right hand in front of
you like you're gonna shake someone's
hand good okay now stick your thumb up
mm-hmm that's the axis of rotation and
now curl your fingers your thumb is
pointing north yes
no I'm declaring that okay by tradition
right okay so if you go to the planet
and curl your fingers in the direction
it's rotating your thumb is gonna point
north on that planet but okay so if I
take Uranus with my thumb up and fingers
curled and I then tip my thumb so it's
pointed downwards your and it's just
Kurt turning back the other way but the
north still has to have that
relationship to that rotation so that's
what defines the north of an object the
right hand rule just by convention
that's how we can say Uranus is rotating
upside down now why do we think that
happens so their South is our North
correct
so they're Australia no there no I do
why did you get me to agree with you on
that your North is their north their
North is their North it just happens to
be in everybody else's occupying the
same area as everyone else's southern
hemisphere that's all but Uranus is it
doesn't have issues here
well Uranus doesn't have much so so we
think in the early solar system because
all the planets would have formed in the
same sort of circular
in cloud and so you don't get
upside-down things in that everybody all
the planets are going the same direction
around the Sun that's the direction the
Sun is rotating as the direction earth
is rotating so everybody's turned in the
same way because that's the enter the
the rotational energy of the original
cloud out of which we formed if you
rotate the other way the way we explain
that is you had some bad stuff happen to
you early on you got slammed by some
other object in the early solar system
that tipped you on your axis so possibly
during we think likely not just possibly
but even likely from the Big Bang no no
way later when we're doing our own solar
system we may made the whole universe
right wait 10 billion years then you get
our solar system ok we're a little late
we're the dust settling so to speak that
very good there we go
very good so it got slammed in in the
early solar system and then it got
tipped it has been that way ever since
so we gotta take another break and when
we're back more cosmic queries
astrophysics household edition when we
return star talk we're back third and
final segment of cosmic queries
household astrophysics edition so what
we call this household everyday everyday
astrophysics household sounds like a
cleaner like these are like tips for you
to get that stove shiny again you know
using household principles so Russell
Peters great to have you on the show so
you got all the questions there I got
all the question to me I don't know if
that's a real name I see Bank Carl
it's an Instagram name anyway what is a
fascinating fact or thought that makes
your appreciation for the universe
overflow wow that's a deep question
that's beautiful yeah that's a beautiful
question let me just hear that question
again I feel we need sax playing what is
a fascinating factor thought that makes
your appreciation for the universe
overflow it in fact in a thought or two
different things I know and ok here goes
here goes i bass
in our collective ignorance on the
frontier of the unknown I longed to look
out look behind me and say hey we got
that and look in front of me and say we
have no idea what that is
and so what keeps me awake at night and
has me run back to my office every
morning is the prospect that we could be
on the heels of a major discovery
answering a question that we might have
posed already but possibly revealing a
question we had not previously known to
ask
that's my muse my cosmic muse I feel you
overflowing I had to give an overflowing
answer
you're like an LA when it rains the LA
River is overflowing so give me more all
right Harry from California they're like
no last name no just Harry do you know
Harry and Calif no but he's scary
leavened bread is his Instagram Harry
hit from California wants to know what
do you think the single most important
discovery in the history of physics is
and why oh I got this okay now physics
or astrophysics are they two different
things it's a physic is a subset of
physics but we good okay we good
some years ago I wrote an essay it won
award from the American Institute of
Physics a writing prize award and the
title the essay was in the beginning and
you're in the chair that I won and it's
stenciled on the back plus I got $3,000
it was just totally cool it's $3,000 is
always a good thing again except I don't
have a few thousand dollars anymore but
I do have the chair because you bought
this damn chair with it so here's here's
what I celebrated in that essay in that
essay I celebrated the existence and the
consequence
of e equals mc-squared on the arc of the
universe there is no understanding of
matter and energy in the universe
without that equation stars would not
produce energy the the the would have
been no Big Bang the everything we take
for granted in this universe owes its
foundation to equals mc-squared
the equivalence of matter and energy in
the universe for me that was the
greatest discovery because of how much
it enabled us to understand
combine that with quantum physics had a
lot of good folks working on it in the
1920s a watershed decade in the history
of human understanding of the universe
quantum physics is a theory of the small
atoms molecules nuclei coming to
understand how the universe works on its
smallest scale made us badass not only
could we have now well bad good and bad
bad take the word bad in both contexts
nice because that empowered us to end
civilization as we know it right the
foundation of the nuclear arsenals the
atom bomb exactly exactly
yet it gave us our deepest understanding
of how the world works and it is the
foundation to the entire information
technology revolution there is no
creation storage or retrieval of
information in the IT universe without
an understanding of the quantum are you
saying hi T because I'm Indian and
that's what my people Excel what did
your people in my favor we excel at I
team aren't you from Toronto yeah but I
got to go back to India for my family
you got famine India I do oh cool
tons oh okay so yet for me equals
mc-squared that's I think the most
profound fact of the universe there's
some close seconds and thirds to in that
list but I put equals mc-squared at the
top so and what's cool is we learned
that in like third grade that's your
first equation right well I was never a
good student oh yeah I became more
curious as I became holder
I wanna cuz I always questioned
everything well that's what that's that
that's it I know you don't need anything
else I know but in the 70s in your
school they would they didn't want you
to question they want you to accept okay
I was like now I got questions about
this and they just boiled me down these
he's an idiot
what did say what are you a comedian the
center one teacher told me I was gonna
be a janitor so okay I showed him right
now he's gonna say oh I did that to
motivate him I'm like no you did yeah I
saw the look in your eye Nair the tone
in your voice
wait but did you find it let's go
off-topic here but they find it
fascinating that so Albert Einstein they
came up with equals mc-squared right
yeah yeah um but it's in such a short
amount of time like it took us how many
you know centuries millennia millennia
to get there and then from then to here
that we just did so much in a short
amount of time
okay like why were we so dumb before
that like what wait is so stupid before
that and then all of a sudden like Oh
BAM okay it looks that way it only looks
that way okay I have books from five
years before equals mc-squared that
would have been the year in 1900 okay I
have books you read those science books
we those books and say the discoveries
of recent years are so vast and so
amazing we are lucky to be living in
special times look at the steam in steam
ships across the ocean we're laying
Telegraph cables we can now communicate
great distances we have the railroads
across the country the world is smaller
than ever before what a great time to be
alive
that's what they're writing in the year
1900 right so that that's what you sound
like today what a great time to be alive
look at all the discoveries we've made
all I'm telling you is when you're
living in a great time every year feels
like you're living in a special time
come back in a hundred years you'll say
those idiots back in 2019 what the hell
did they know yeah well yeah you can go
back to 1999 and like a computer it
you know right no no in 1999
no one has any concept yet of a
smartphone yeah well we had the Palm
Pilot I believe I had I had a Palm Pilot
had a Palm Pilot and I know that was
pretty good yeah you thought it was
great I remember you I remember 1987
movie Wall Street yes okay in that movie
there's gecko on the beach in the
Hamptons with a cell phone yes and it's
like shoulder-mounted a cell phone yeah
right as he I remember because I saw
that movie in first-run and I remembered
wow that's cool he could walk and
there's no wires and he's talking on a
phone and any of us today looking at the
essay what the hell were we thinking
I remember my brother's first cell phone
was about about the size of that book
that physics energy book and you had the
book on my tea it had a handle that
pulled out oh you know it still had like
a receiver to cut like a uh-huh okay and
the buttons were separate it was but it
was portable it was portable I used to
sit in my brother's car and talked to my
girlfriend at the time like 1988 Dave
showing off in front of your girlfriend
you know because he had free minutes
after like 9:00 o'clock so I would use
it then and it wasn't long distance
didn't matter the right right right so
so the evidence you're living in special
times is that at every moment you think
you're living in a special time okay
okay but okay let's go with not just
equals every schooling let's say from
like 8 the mid-1800s
mm-hmm - now we made some big strides
but what was happening before that that
just we were not doing anything it just
seems like we've okay you don't want to
go back then in the middle of the 1800s
we discovered and perfected and
harnessed electricity right that's what
I'm saying then when all that started
since you want to go before like it
before that like this goes seventeen
hundred's Oh Oh like we were just like
what we're really the steam engine okay
steamships excuse me all right all right
just all right let's go sixteen hundreds
1600s
we discovered that earth goes around the
Sun the earth is not in the middle of
the known universe that guy's name again
mez galileo galileo yes see yeah
yeah okay just checking so no they were
discovery making sure your next show I'm
making sure you're legit all monitors
isn't just Internet's trickery it is
true that discoveries happened
less frequently right it is less likely
that there was an engineering discovery
that would change your life at that time
that is true but think of the mindset if
any discovery changed your life at that
time that was amazing
right but that's previously it didn't
change anybody's life who change it over
generations right that's when things
were selling like hotcakes what I'm
saying is people cared about hotcakes at
that yes that was the best part of their
day and he go later other advances in
medicine and we discovered cures and
there was so yeah but I mean what I'm
saying is like they were all farther
apart you know spread apart more and
they seem like 1700s into the 1800s we
invent the chronometer that seaworthy so
we can figure out longitude on earth
which has precision navigation this
stuff you think you live in special
times just go back then and you'll be
celebrating that I'm just saying no but
I'm saying what I'm saying is is that I
feel like every day we're discovering
something new that's gonna change our
lives but now there's so many things
coming in there's so many things that
we're discovering that that they hold
back on us now like it's too much for
you yeah yeah we got to be nice yeah we
got I was talking to a computer guy the
other night he was tell me about
technology that is about to be
introduced
mm-hmm to the public he said but we've
had this for over 12 years
okay and now they're introducing it to
the public they make it seem like it's
the newest greatest thing because but
this isn't right they have a market
ability of the other stuff and they want
to get their money's worth that right is
it the R&D that produced it yes yeah
yeah so there's so much Hold'em bats an
interesting concept so if we keep this
up we could be a century behind what we
could be doing Julia who trying to make
a buck all the stuff that they invented
a hundred years exactly okay interesting
this is an interesting conspiracy theory
I don't know if it's conspiracy or if
it's just a hypothesis we only have a
couple of minutes left I'm gonna go into
lightning round
okay so ask me five questions and I'll
give you
soundbite answers to him okay all right
from the classifieds bell for me we'd
have to simulate them okay ready go okay
here ready on the earth and the moon
become EE double tidally locked what
effect would that have on tides and
weather patterns Oh excellent so the
moon is spiraling away from Earth at the
rate of a few inches a year
one effect of that is that Earth is
slowing down in our rotation we have to
put in leap seconds every now and then
you know the moon is trying to do what
it's trying to slow us down so that one
day on earth equals one month for the
moon when that happens we will always
show the same face to the moon now when
that happens there will be no tides at
all tides will end
really yeah well moon tides will wind
will still have Sun tides but the moon
tides will end yeah put our moon tides
exactly the moon strength the gravity of
the Moon across the earth stretches the
earth the part of you have close to the
moon pulls closer to the moon
part that's farther away is farthest
away and it stretches and Earth rotates
inside of those tidal bulges you're at
the beach and the tide comes in the tide
comes out goes out nothing's coming in
and out you are rotating on the solid
earth in and out of a tidal bulge caused
by the moon and the Sun on the ocean
surface is it like when you're in a
bathtub with water and you start rocking
back and forth the water starts it'll
know because in that case it's the water
that's moving okay in this case it looks
like the water's moving but it's not
it's you rotating into it hardly anyone
knows that because colloquially we talk
about tides moving in and out mm-hmm but
we are rotating into the tidal bulge and
out of the tidal bulge and there'll be a
point where the tides won't the tides
will just be static and they'll never
change so that is inevitable and it
it'll take longer for that to happen
than the future life expectancy of the
Sun so don't worry about it okay so okay
well that that's a concern also give a
short answer to that question well I
hope even one last one go how similar
must an exoplanet be to earth in order
to host human life oh you know I think
we can handle a planet that has slightly
less gravity what do you weigh here on
earth 185 pounds well thank you but 215
250
do we patent it it's big boy it's big
boy you were talking about the you know
if you go to a plant an exoplanet with
slightly less gravity in your way 190
pounds mmm you're not gonna complain
slightly more gravity if your heart is
strong and you a to 30 to 40 you're not
gonna complain so don't take me back up
there and so there's a range you won't
be fatter you'll just weigh more your
weight is not only how many molecules
you have in you
it's the densest it's also what's the
force of gravity operating on you so you
weigh more but you won't look heavier
you'll just be heavier so so so my mass
will be the same mass will be the same
correct but your weight can be less or
more depending on what planet you're on
in fact it's less or more on earth if
you go to the equator and the equator is
spinning the equator you're moving a
thousand miles an hour you weigh less on
the equator than you do here in New York
City you weigh less on a mountaintop
than you do in a cave we should go to
the equator game they should have
weigh-ins for finds at the equator
equator at the equator and if you had a
mountain on the equator you weigh less
than any other place on earth that's it
could see that you're gonna propose it
to the UFC but you have to ascend the
mountain yeah you lose the weight that
you would have hoped you'd lose by being
a lower gravity well just by climbing
the mountain so you better off just but
it's not all that much weight you pee
out more weight than you would lose by
going to the equator no it's ounces it's
not pounds well then I'd be pissed if I
went through all that Russell we got to
go why the sued this is so much fun
thanks we got to do this again yes maybe
some through town yes if you have world
tourists there you know world performer
but I come to New York well it's got to
be in your soul somewhere it's
definitely in my soul
very good all my favorite place on earth
Russell great to have you but you've
been listening to and possibly even
watching Startalk cosmic queries thank
you to Russell Peters and one of the
only and as always I bid you to keep
looking up
you